a lot of people hate white people these
days
it seems to be a popular kind of idea in
the culture and since I am one of the
swarthy Sicilian people a racially
liminal ethnically ambiguous sort of
fellow I guess white but you know
there's a conversation to be had I
consider myself an almost impartial
Observer of this phenomenon take it away
so I recently got a lot of new followers
most of which seem to be white let's do
a little run down baby I don't like
white people I'm not gonna follow you
back
please
please now that's pretty racist but I'm
not a nice person but I am a kind person
I learned that from Mickey Kendall in
her book Hood feminism I sort of think
it's the opposite I I bet she is a nice
person but not a kind person Alan Bloom
made fun of this word nice in his book
the closing the American mind he said
the the best thing I can say about
American college students today is that
they're nice which is also the worst
thing you can say about them because it
means just glib shallow superficial but
but not really partaking of Charity so
if This Woman's gonna come out and say I
hate white people I'm not going to
follow you back you guys are terrible
but I'm really nice I'm really I'm I'm
not nice but I'm kind no you are nice
you are glib and you are superficial but
you don't seem to have very much charity
I'm kind to people who are kind to this
body if you are not kind to this body I
will say some not nice words to You and
then I will block you I don't Value
white people's feelings emotions or
bodies over my own
oh no
so if you came here thinking that you
were going to get to talk about yourself
if you came here thinking that anything
was going to be about you you're
confused and you can go I'm really good
at reading through comments that people
send with niceties meaning if you're
really racist but you just say it in a
really nice way I'm gonna know I don't
like when white people explain things
about themselves in my comment section
when I'm trying to talk about racism I
think I get this now
this is just a kind of porn right if you
are a white person and you are following
this black lady's rants about how much
she hates white people it probably just
titillates you doesn't it I've known
guys
some friends of mine even
who really seem to like it when women
are mean to them
she's too good drinks just too good and
they just really like it I think why are
you allowing this woman to say and do
this oh no what am I going to do they
seem to get a kick out of it and so
that's what this is okay this is not a
serious disputation on the politics of
race this is a kind of porn for
self-flagellating white people but I I
think I get it their infrastructures of
harm that intersect with racism your
personal experience as a white person
regardless of what other marginalizing
ideas you hold is not what I'm talking
about and my comment section is never
the place for that unfortunately I have
to spell out these rules because
historically y'all things up I kind
of like what she says here she says even
if you check other intersectional boxes
even if you're marginalized in some
other way I don't care if you're white
you're dead you're dead to me because
the way intersectionality operates today
is if you can check any box you'll get
some points it's just if you can't check
any box if you're a straight white man
who knows that he's a man you're the
devil but if you can if you can say well
but I'm gay I'm gay that's the Pete
bootage strategy is he's the blandest
whitest guy you ever saw in your whole
life but he can say well I'm gay and so
he's a good person if he weren't gay
he'd be an evil person but because he's
gay he's a good person but what this
woman is doing she's really ratcheting
the resentment up to 11. because she's
saying no I don't care if you check
every other box if you are white I hate
you what's your favorite name to call
white people I've seen some of the most
creative names on this app but this one
from one of my favorite mutuals
absolutely Takes the Cake this is why we
have so much hesitation when it comes to
calling ghost crickets cause girl what
is that
goes to crickets I saw one of the names
on there was flower Rangers I don't know
that's kind of funny I don't really have
a problem with that but I don't have a
problem with racial insults if they're
made in jest I think it's totally fine
you can say I think you can make a joke
about whatever race of people or almost
really any attribute if it's made in
good faith and charity I think it's
totally fine now of course if I ever
were to say even the most charitable
obvious joke about any of the Sacred
unspeakable privileged races of people I
would be cast into the outer Darkness
where there's whaling and National teeth
but I don't take offense that's kind of
fun ghost Cricket that's kind of funny
more on that in just one second first
though head on over to expressvpn.com
Michael YT it is extremely important to
protect your online privacy with a VPN
choosing a VPN that you trust is equally
as important expressvpn is my favorite
VP and it is super easy to install on
all of my devices phone laptop you can
put it on your tablet click one button
you are protected extremely
straightforward and I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market number one expressvpn
doesn't log your online activity they've
developed a trusted server technology
makes it impossible for their servers to
store any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can even stream HD videos
with zero buffering three expressvpn is
incredibly easy to use just fire up the
app and tap one button to connect it's
not just me saying this Business Insider
The Verge and many other Tech journals
write expressvpn the number one VPN in
the world protect yourself with the VPN
I trust use expressvpn.com Michael YT
today get three months free in a
one-year package
expresvpn.com
michaelyt expressvpn.com Michael y t a
lot of white allies and accomplices ask
how can they support black and
indigenous people of color
and
sometimes I really don't know what to
say but here's one easy way
just don't have babies
oh man that is a racist yes
I am racist have you ever heard the term
white genocide bro what are you talking
about man like Q Anon or any of these
other things I see it pop up from the
left talking about the right and they
say these crazy right-wingers believe
that left-wing people want the white
people to go extinct and you say oh
really okay well all right why did I
turn into CNN today but then here's the
crazy part is you tune in to some left
Winger and he says I want the white
people to go extinct
or or you tune into academic discourse
dating back to the mid-2000s out of
left-wing political science institutions
and circles and they would say the way
that we're going to win is by the
demographic decline of the white people
in the United States and this is
published in a lauded very popular
political science text and then talked
about in the New York Times and then
talked about on CNN and then talked
about on all sorts of left-wing papers
but then if you just repeat back the
words that they said to you you're
called a crazy conspiracy theorist
racist phobic evil okay has anyone
actually like definitively addressed or
answered the question of why white
people smell like pennies when it rains
like this is not even like
do we I don't I don't know I think this
is true of every race I don't know about
pennies in the rain but races which tend
to have cultures there tends to be at
least a somewhat significant overlap
between race and culture tend to have
attributes that are visible and that
sometimes you can hear in terms of
sounds they can't understand a word and
smells
of course if you go hang out with your
Indian buddy and he's in an Indian home
and they have Indian food and they do
Indian things
there's a fair chance that it's going to
smell a little bit more like Curry than
if you were visiting your Italian or
Irish friend okay and so the idea that
dif that that white people have a
certain smell to them yeah I guess
that's true I assume every race and
culture has peculiarities of of sense
it's just like a statement of fact white
people be smelling like pennies and
quarters when they get wet like when it
rains
and it seems to be it does seem to be
specific to white people does anyone
know why
I don't know why that one that one
tickled me so much okay all right I
gotta we gotta move on this is not like
racism it is racism anti-fatness is
rooted in anti-blackness and the reason
why people are pursuing thinness is
because they're pursuing proximity to
whiteness the reason why people hate fat
people there's actually something to
this point no anti-fatness is not rooted
in anti-blackness or anything like that
but I do remember during covid black
women have higher rates of death from
all sorts of problems you know in all
sorts of medical conditions the libs
presented this as an argument for the
white supremacy of the medical system
but that's not the case it's it's
because black women tend to be obese at
much higher rates than than white women
are or women of other races so the
co-morbidity is not Blackness it's
obesity paradoxically this is a terrible
problem we have to fix this problem but
then when you try to fix the problem you
say okay well maybe you know you need to
lose some weight we'll say well that's
anti-blackness black people are are
Oprah rest because they are more likely
to be obese but if you try to stop black
people from being obese that is an
example of Oppression so it just becomes
this circle and it never ends keep going
and appearing and curvier bigger is
associated with Blackness especially
black women and that's why they're
discriminated in the workplace overly
sexualized and this has gone back for
centuries and centuries overly
sexualized there was another controversy
that came out I remember over the dating
apps which is that on the dating apps
black women are swiped at a lower rate I
guess than other people in the dating
apps and this was called a an example of
discrimination racism or whatever but
but which is it is it that black women
are over sexualized or under sexualized
in the case of obesity as this woman is
describing is it that obesity is looked
on as being repulsive I'm a big trouble
lied and you have every reason to be
ashamed of me or that obesity is looked
on it being extremely sexually
attractive which is that she's she's
making contradictory points about the
same people and so if this were a
problem there would be no way to fix it
because anything you do would be called
evil and racist and discriminatory so
you're damned if you do and you're
damned if you don't cap sexism racism it
all comes back to white supremacy which
is the foundation of the fabric of
America and rules every sector and
aspect of our society well there it is
it's just every problem is white
supremacy even problems that are in
opposition to one another somehow white
supremacy is the cause of all of it
because that's not the conclusion of her
investigation that would be the premise
and so when the only tool you got is a
hammer every problem starts to look like
a nail my favorite video is obviously
the quarters and pennies one it's not
because I think it's the craziest one I
think it's probably the least crazy one
I don't know I wouldn't be surprised if
if two non-white people white people
have this particular smell in the rain
like Denny's I don't know it's just
really really funny that's my favorite
one there you go there you have it see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]